but for you
thanks for coming I realize for those of
you for submitting papers to stop one of
the people keeping you from working on
your stock submission so thanks for
coming and for those of you who are
waiting for lunch I'm also one of the
people cooking up some lunch so again
thanks for coming so they're a bunch of
a bunch of jargon in this title
hopefully I'll explain what the jargon
means this is joint work with Kieran
Thiago and Aaron sit for Aaron is a
colleague and a Missoni and Karen is a
student who's jaunty advice by Aaron at
Stanford okay so let me start with a
simple problem in stock is about a
simple problem I wanna if anything I
want to just explain what this problem
is so setting is that we have some
unknown distribution over the domain and
we have access to this distribution via
samples we like to estimate some
property of this distribution so we have
access to n iid samples on the
distribution and based on this
we'd like to say something about some
property of this distribution it's a
very simple question somewhat broad try
to get a little more specific well think
about symmetric properties properties
that are don't depend on the actual
identities of the objects have we seen a
sample for example if it was a urn of
colored balls I care about some property
that depends on the distribution but not
about how many red balls there are how
many blue balls there are and so on and
so forth it doesn't matter if all of the
labels were permitted to value the
property would be the same so for
example the entropy is is such a
property the support size such a
property and so on so interesting
properties that don't actually depend on
the actual labels they just depend on
the histogram
okay so I'm basically gonna ask this
question of how well we can estimate
this property based on a sample right so
so now let me tell you about the other
notion which is in the title which is
this notion of profile maximum
likelihood so again let's think about a
simple setting we have a domain of size
3 so a elements a B and C and say we
pick three iron examples let's say we
get a first let me get be next let me
get a so a sequence of samples a ba now
we'll say that the profile of the sample
is just a vector of frequencies okay
and just for convenience of sort this
vector of frequencies so the highest
numbers are clear first so I'll say the
profile of this sequence ABA
is 2 comma 1 and you know this this term
this concept is called by different
names some doesn't call the pattern
sometimes called the histogram we may
call it the profile okay all right
so let's suppose we had suppose the
online distribution was P then we can
say what's the probability that I see
the actual sequence ABA what's wrong
that the first element was a the next
element will be the next element was a
he and this probability will be P a
square times P right go ask another
question we could say what's the
probability of seeing a sequence whose
profile was 2 comma 1 now if you wanted
to think about what's the problem using
a sequences profilers to go on one there
are a few different ways you might see
this you might see two A's and Abby you
might see two bees and C you might see
two either C and so on so there's six
different possibilities and then for
each of them there are three ways in
which those elements could be permitted
okay so we've got to add up the
probabilities of each of these
possibilities and that gives us the
probability of seeing a sequence whose
profile is 2 comma 1 right so we'll
think of this as the probability of the
profile ok so the two things will be two
concepts of week yeah one was what's the
probability of seeing a particular
sequence and then the second one was
what's probably of seeing a particular
profile so order doesn't counts in which
you observe these things right
the order doesn't cut yeah
we sort of explicitly according to that
you alright good so now let me talk
about two notions of maximum like your
one that you're very familiar with
another one which I want to tell you
about okay so given a sequence let's
look at the profile of the sequence the
usual notion of maximum likelihood is
what I call the sequence maximum likely
what's the probability P that would
maximize the probability of having seen
this particular sequence of elements so
this is the sequence maximum likelihood
problem so you have access to a bunch of
samples look at the samples then you say
what's the underlying distribution that
will maximize the probability of seeing
this particular sequence okay what do
you think it is
it's just the empirical distribution
right so it's just the distribution that
you see over this sample so it's the
counts divided by the length okay let's
ask a different question what's the
probability distribution that maximizes
the probability of seeing something of
this particular profile so this I'm
gonna call the profile maximum
likelihood okay so what's the
probability distribution which maximizes
their property of seeing a sequence that
has exactly the profile that we saw all
right slightly different somewhat
unintuitive it's not quite clear what
this is doing so that's the evens take
some examples okay so we had our earlier
example where we had a sequence ABA the
profile was 2 comma 1 and we said Laurie
did this right the sequence maximum
likelihood was 2/3 1/3
what's the profile max1 like it
any ideas
turns out that is actually uniform over
two elements okay so don't doubt that
the profile maximum likelihood is
actually the uniform distribution over
to our right it's it's it's a
calculation you can sit down and try to
do it yourself so notice I'm not telling
you that my universe has two elements if
you look over all possible sets of
distributions you'll find that the one
that maximizes the profiles maximum like
it is in fact the uniform distribution
over what if we had profile 2 1 1 so we
saw two of one element one of another
element 1
ok so again the sequence Malcolm like
here we know same vertical distribution
what happens to the profile maximum
likely
still suit uniform okay so it's not
always uniform in this case it is so
just I should have given you an example
where it's not uniform but it's not
always uniform but in this case it is
uniform it's actually uniform with five
elements it turns out that the profile
maximum-likelihood is actually uniform
of five elements is weird somewhat
strange but it shows this interesting
property that this concept of profile
maximum like it seems to automatically
incorporate this feature that you know
there are likely elements of your
distribution that you haven't seen in
yourself okay so this is somewhat is a
concept but people do try to wrap their
heads around try to figure out how to
handle this in some sense this profile -
unlikely scene to incorporate this you
know it is predicting and even though
you've seen a sample of four elements
you only seen three distinct elements
you know there could be elements you
know distribution area LLC all right so
we don't think about this distortion of
profile maximum the reason I spend so
much time on the slide is just to make
sure that we're all comfortable with
this idea of profile maximum likelihood
okay it's a very simple intuitive I
think very appealing concept okay just
make sure I think I miss something
the other bit is not give it to you
before him let's say I don't tell you
what is I mean you could also think
about situations where I know something
else so you might apply this for example
in settings we are trying to estimate
the set of websites do you have a sample
and you're trying to support size you
don't know a priori about the supports I
hit number species problem yeah exactly
so this better example if I already if I
tell you that the size of the alphabet
is three what would be the performance
movement because I hope you observed ABC
and X its threes yeah
good question so I didn't haven't done
that calculation maybe
I'm guessing as uniform over three if
that's if you do that but I'm not sure
yeah
so intuitively it feels like things that
are symmetric under perturbations of
deliveries they would probably always
leave the uniform because we're good
things that are you know profile this is
symmetric thank you renamed yeah the
profile would simply say well let's see
this suppose I drew a sample of a
hundred and ninety-nine of them happen
to be one element and one happened to be
some other element the uniform
distribution of two elements is not
going to be so it stops at I mean these
simple examples are the pretty small
numbers so you can actually get the
wrong conclusion you can get the wrong
and ution from these simple examples so
it does matter how large these numbers
are in fact in your profile if you have
some very large numbers you know I'm
going to put uniform distribution so
yeah it's not entirely obvious what
these values ought to be and there's
it's there's something very
counterintuitive about what this profile
is unlikely it gives you okay so you
know what is how do you compute this
profile maximum likely so first of all
let's ask the following question suppose
you have distribution P how do you
compute the probability of seeing this
particular profile if your underlying
distribution was P okay so you can do
this it's a it's not very hard you can
write on an expression and one way to
write on an expression is to say that
this underlying probability is
proportional to the permanent of a
certain matrix okay one way to do this
would be to say
so there's gonna be a combinatorial term
okay and that there's going to be a
permanent the the permanent is gonna be
the following if you have probabilities
P I for elements you have frequencies F
J in your sample then this IJ at entry
of this permanent is going to be this
matrix is going to be VI ^ okay and
you're gonna have so if you try to
figure out what what this probability is
going to be there's going to be a
combinatorial term and then you're going
to want to sum up over all terms of this
power it's not very hard to see so the
fact that this is a permanent seems to
suggest well okay this particular way of
formulating the problem leads to a
permanent which seems to suggest it's
maybe a difficult thing to do you don't
know for sure we can't compute the
permanent to put an arbitrary accuracy
yjm Sinclair was running for example
we're asking the question not for a
given probability we're saying what's
the probability there but maximize it
has the feeling of a hard problem okay
although I don't have proof of this all
right
there are few different heuristic
algorithms have been proposed for this
problem actually they were the original
paper that proposed this notion of
profile maximum likelihood this was
joint work why I don't know let's see
and it's collaborators and he and his
collaborators have developed this notion
over a sequence of papers this was the
paper they introduced the idea today
said they suggested an expectation
maximization heuristic to do this there
are a few other approaches that have
been used as one you know this is all
theory about approximating prominence
and there's something called the Betty
free-energy approximation of a permanent
that's been used to try to approximate
this and then recently there was an
interesting dynamic programming
heuristic public in Jo and Wiseman and
again tries to approximate this
profile maximum life here okay none of
these actually have any guarantees but
people try to experiment with these and
see how well they're performing for data
sets of interest right okay so let me
say a little bit about why we might be
interested in this profile maximum like
you know I think it's a very simple
intuitive concept so I think it's a
natural object of study there's another
reason why you might want to be int you
might be interested in this idea in this
profile maximum likelihood okay so let
me talk a little bit about estimating
symmetric properties remember you know a
symmetric property is one that's
invariant to permutations or the labels
now the profile of the sample is
actually a sufficient statistic for
symmetrical so if you're interested in a
symmetric property you don't actually
care about the label
you guys all throw them away hey so
again let's look at this problem of
trying to estimate a symmetric property
given access to and samples there's a
bunch of literature on this a bunch of
different properties have been studied
for example support something on support
coverage entropy distant some uniformity
and for each of these now by now we know
you know very good bounds matching upper
and lower bounds in many cases so what's
the optimum number of samples are you
need okay and in many of these cases
there are customized estimators for each
of these so you have a box for one
another estimator works for the other
one so on so forth one question you
could ask is is there a universal
approach is there a way by which you
could use one method and actually design
estimators for all of these different
properties and interestingly in a recent
paper they showed that this is indeed
the case
so profile maximum likelihood
indeed can serve as a universal
approximator Universal estimator for
symmetric property so what they're
saying is consider the following
approach take your sample compute the
profile maximum likely distribution
compute your property of interest on
this profile maximum likelihood
distribution and output that as your
estimator and this is gonna be
competitive with respect to the best
estimator for symmetric properties under
some technical conditions which I'm not
gonna bother defining precisely here but
for a wide class of symmetric properties
this approach is going to give you
nearly optimum estimate is attractive
that's what's one good reason why we
might care about doing this I would say
whatever in by that that that means that
I get my estimate to within one plus my
ultimate
all right so does it include all the
examples yeah the examples were designed
were chosen because they actually fit
yes so there's a little bit of caveat I
mean you're losing constant factor you I
think this this theorem loses constant
factor so if there was an optimum
estimator uses n samples this one will
use order of n zone I see we're losing a
little bit but it's one approach that
works for all of these methods there is
there is a technical condition that they
this this theorem is not saying that
this works for any symmetric property it
works for symmetric properties where the
optimum estimators have a certain
Lipschitz which is something that I'm
not I'm not talking about here and
hiding under the carpet well you should
go look at this this paper if you want
to see more rows I mean this this is
more a motivation for why this profile I
swim like that question is an
interesting one there's also the results
in the decision saying that if you can
optimally estimated aspect thus water
distribution you can also plug in and
get optimal aspects is it it is more
interesting thing I know there's such a
such a result this is not necessarily
saying the same thing this is saying
specifically about this profile maximum
like there's something about the form of
this objective function and lends itself
to this kind of here so I I don't think
that two theorems are the same in climb
you also get an optimal as
assorted distribution does it imply that
or maybe the other way around that's a
solid situation it give you enough you
know I'm not sure good question that I'm
not sure what's the implication for
estimating is all registration I mean I
need to figure out what is your what's
the error measure but anyway we can we
can chat about that I'm not sure about
the answer that question all right other
questions
okay here's another amazing thing if you
thought that this theorem was
interesting it turns out that you don't
have to get the exact profile maximum
likelihood
it's a physis to get an approximate
profile maximum like your distribution
so suppose you know you weren't able to
optimize this profile maximum likelihood
objective you were able to output some
other distribution such that the
objective function which is the probe
probability using this profile not quite
the highest but within a factor of e to
the N to the one minus Delta that's also
good enough it turns out
so here's an approximation factor of e
to the N is is trivial or it's it's
pretty straightforward to get it maybe
even the sequence
maximum-likelihood will give you that
but doing a little bit better than that
will give you those two
so here that's the open question the
open question is can we get anything
slightly better than e to the end why
does the approximation need to be so
good because why does the approximation
need to be so what matters here is how
many profiles are you're saying why is
it the case that this kind of
approximation is good enough for this
application overkill but I mean they're
just like just something that comes to
mind now work
worry not no no we're not assuming that
F is Lipschitz okay necessarily there is
a certain Lipchitz property which I
haven't defined for the optimum
estimator so this is not something which
is there's another theorem that applies
to a you can't look at a property and
say yes this this theorem applies to
this you have to design an estimator for
that property that has this Lipschitz
like condition and then you can verify
if this theorem applies so it's a little
more subtle all right okay so the main
result is that we can actually get such
an estimator so we can get an estimator
that has approximation e to the N to the
2/3
that's know so the approximation is
purely in the objective function right
so the objective function was what's the
problem okay so you're given a profile
you want to find a distribution then
maximize the probability of seeing the
profile okay so the probability of
seeing the profile is the value of the
objective function we're going to get us
a different distribution not the best
one but for this different distribution
the probability in the profile will be
no worse than a factor of e to the N to
the 2/3 right sorry explain why that's
the right scaling so the likelihood can
be 1 not e to the minus sign it like it
has a fairly large range okay so somehow
you're saying no matter what the
distribution is that value of beta is
good enough and I say you're going to
give me a fee that approximates the
likelihood to that factor yes somehow
distribution independent in the sense
some distributions like I mean the
likelihood is not scale that nicely and
I just don't understand how this works
so you're saying that the the objective
functions are probably itself has a wide
range yeah everything between 1 and e to
the minus n ok so so why is it the case
that this is is this possible or this is
interesting
or is the question just like somehow
why shouldn't the beta depends on the
scale of the likelihood for that
problems I mean why should there be such
a beta independent of the distribution
maybe until that is is let's let's work
through the presentation and then maybe
maybe you'll get the answer to that so
okay so one one thing to check is that
you can get an e to the n approximation
so that sort of suggests that yes in
principle you can get something it
doesn't depend on your you're not making
the assumption but just version you can
get you to the end right that's an
indication that something is possible
now you're asking you know can you do
better than need at the end that's one
way to think about oh I'm just saying
that it just it's a prices to get a
little improvement in this exponent so
you can get e to the minus n either n
whatever you just could get n to the
instead of n to the power of one if you
get to the end of the power of 1 minus
something that's all I'm saying ok
alright ok so let me just that this is
not the only way by which you can get
Universal estimators there are a bunch
of different approaches have been said
suggested in the literature so profile
maximum likelihood transmitted I said
the one big open problem but roses can
you actually do this efficiently so if
you could do broken hymen lightly or
thanks to it so we this is the exactly
the problem that we address you know
other approaches there's a linear
programming based objective of approach
which was really suggested by Efron and
he stood and then valiant and valiant
develop this idea and and use this to
design estimators for a couple different
properties and there's another approach
which is sort of a functional
approximation approach which has also
been used there's a recent paper by its
honcho and and Wiseman that does a
method called Lopez moment matching that
that follows this particular approach
again they got Universal estimators this
this is this also applies to what's
called the Gaussian setting which these
previous approaches don't apply to okay
so I just want to say that this is not
the only way by which you could tell you
know much less matters there are other
ways I think this profile maximum like
here is a is an interesting way to do it
and so be motivated to work on the
problem because without it's a cute
interesting question which has nice
application ok all right so I won't say
much about the slide I just wanted to
say that look you there are different
approaches that he could use to design
estimators and the big question with
using this profile maximum likely
approaches was that we didn't order
efficiently now we can
all right so let me tell you a little
bit okay so it's been a lot of time
trying to motivate the problem hopefully
I've got you all fired up and now I want
to tell you how we actually do it okay
so ten minutes so let's see how far we
can go all right so we we already talked
about two different problems right we
talked about we start with maximum
likely or to talk about profile maximum
likelihood we're gonna define a bunch of
other problems okay so bear with me
first we're going to define a
discretized version then we're going to
define a slight variant of this
discretized version then we're gonna
take a convex relaxation of this
objective that's gonna give us a rather
say a little bit about this sequence
mostly I hope I'll focus on this
sequence of reformulations of the
problem we're gonna take our original
problem maybe a massage in a few
different ways so there's it gets
converted in something that we can
actually solve right we did some
experiments maybe I won't spend that
much time on that but if you understood
I can show you some things okay
so it's how do we reformulate the
problem that's okay so we have our
distribution we have a sequence of
samples yeah profile we already define
the sequence probability we also define
the profile probability this is our
objective function okay so this is the
thing that we want to approximate all
right so we're trying to solve this
problem we're trying to find the
probability P that maximizes this
objective function okay all right and
we're gonna focus on approximation
algorithms make sure I said this before
this is what we want right we want to
find some other distribution such that
its objective function is guaranteed to
be beta times our
all right so few different things we're
gonna try to impose some structure or an
hour solution okay so one simple thing
to ask is can we guarantee that the
smallest probability in our distribution
is not too small okay and turns out that
we can do this so you can always
guarantee that there is a solution that
gives you a good value for the objective
and has not too small probability so the
minimum probability that has is at least
1 over 2 n square so now what we gonna
do is we're gonna take up our V
distribution and say well in general
probably distribution would have a bunch
of values we saw examples where the
value is 1/2 one fair let's look at all
the distinct values that it has don't
try to ensure that it has only a small
number of distinct values so in fact
we're gonna have to give up on the
notion of strict property distributions
in a sense there are probabilities may
no longer add up to exactly one it'll be
less than equal one that's fine could
still plug into our objective function
and evaluate it and you can always scale
them up and raise a real probability
distribution all right so now I'm going
to I'm going to stipulate that all of my
probability values are gonna lie in a
small set ok and my set is gonna be able
to following form we're gonna take
multiples of 1 plus Epsilon I'm gonna
take power is a 1 plus epsilon 1 B 1
such powers of 1 plus epsilon 1 B 1 by
the way is something like log n over
epsilon 1 because I said all by
probably's range from 1 over 2n squared
to one and they go up in multiples of 1
perceptron okay so how much do we lose
in trying to massage about we'll
probably distribution so that all of its
values lie in the set not too much it
turns out that we can guarantee that you
can produce such a massage distribution
and the value of the objective function
changes by at most e to the epsilon 1/n
this is entirely believable all right
the other thing we're gonna do is we're
going to say that you can look at the
profile itself this is the frequencies
by which we see the elements we can
massage those too yeah so again these
profile the values of frequencies of the
elements we see could be arbitrary
integers right it'd be nice if they they
they took on only a small set of values
so again we're gonna do we're gonna say
let's let's allow them to only take on
values of the form 1 plus for this
epsilon 2 epsilon 2 by 2 here powers of
1 plus epsilon 2 right
okay so we're gonna restrict our profile
to only take values in this set again
the number of such values are about log
n over epsilon two we're going to take
our profile the real profile we're going
to discretize it in a sense of rounding
up all the frequencies to the next power
of 1 plus epsilon 2 by 2 it lies on this
side again this modifies the objective
function a little bit but not too much
you can show that the change in the
objective function is at most e to the
power of epsilon to n log so with two
things we discretize the probabilities
we discretize the profile
okay so now we ready to talk about a
first new problem so we had profile
maximum likelihood the discrete profile
maximum likelihood problem says find me
a distribution not arbitrary
distribution but a discrete pseudo
distribution one who's probably values
can only take values from this
structured set that I had that maximize
the probability of not the actual
profile but the discretized version of
the asked can we find discretized for a
distribution that maximize the
probability of the discretized form and
we just argued okay I just claimed that
this new problem has objective function
which is not too bad
compared to the original problem this is
exactly the law as long as I control my
epsilon 1 and epsilon 2 I'll be fine
okay so now you know the whole point of
doing this discretization was to say
that remember I said that when you want
to compute the probability of seeing a
particular profile for a given proper
distribution it corresponds to having
you know this is permanent as permanent
is little unwieldly okay so what we're
gonna do is because we have this nice
grouping of probabilities and and
frequencies we're going to try to say
that a lot of the terms that arise in
this permanent can be clubbed together
okay so how exactly can they be clubbed
together so one way to think about how
exactly they can be clubbed together is
to say that if you want to figure out
you know what's the probability of
seeing its particular profile what you
have to do is the following so on the
bottom you have elements of different
probabilities this is your underlying
distribution and then
and you have your frequencies this is
what you actually observe in your
profile in computing the probability of
seeing this particular profile you're
gonna have to say well let's say we had
some number of elements from here appear
so many times some number of elements
from here up here so many times some
number of alums from here up here so
many times and so on so forth
you got to specify in some sense the
edges of this by paragraph how many
elements fall from this set of
probabilities were observed so many
times in your sequence right so this
pattern this is but this bipartite graph
the values of these edges I'm going to
refer to that as a pipe okay now within
a particular type which is once I
specify how many elements flow from here
to here there's still many many choices
you still have to figure out which
elements of this set precisely went here
which elements of this set went here and
so and so forth there's still a lot of
terms in here right but they all grouped
very nicely so that the probability term
for all of them is exactly the same
right that's the whole point okay so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna look
at our our probabilities here our
frequencies and we're going to look at
this bipartite graph okay we're going to
look at all possible values so we could
put on this bipartite graph and the way
which we the way which we provide
library graph well we know that we have
a certain number of elements that need
to be need to appear some number of
times obviously then if you look at the
sum of the edges of this bipartite graph
this is that Muslims
there's also a probability constraint
okay what's the probability constraint
well one way to write the probability
constraint is to say that if I sum up
the probabilities of all the elements I
should get at most one okay another way
to write the probability constraint
would be I actually have numbers at the
bottom which tell me how many elements
of each probably class there are and
then I just say well I have the
cardinality constraint some of the edges
some other instance okay okay good so
what's the key point the key point is
that my objective function can be
written as a sum over all of these types
where each type includes okay so there
is a there's a combinatorial term here
which depends only on the profile and
nothing else
okay and then I'm gonna sum over times
write each type includes a probability
term which is fixed for that type and
then in combinatorial term right so you
aggregated a whole bunch of terms okay
so now we're gonna say is we're gonna
simplify this we're gonna say figured
about trying to sum up over all types
let's just find the one type that gives
us the maximum contribution right I
start to find the one type that gives us
maximum contribution and that's going to
be our new word or our next optimization
problem right how much did we lose in
doing this well in general there are
many types our objective function is
getting contribution from all of these
okay now we just said let's focus on one
how much do we lose well exactly the
number of types right so how many
different bipartite graphs can you have
matching the top to the bottom okay well
we had b1 terms here be two terms here
each of these there are b1 b2 numbers
right and each of them can take values
let's say 1 through n that's a generous
upper bound so number of numbers that we
have a number of such types as n ^ b 1 b
2 b 1 if you remember was log in our
epsilon 1 b 2 was log in our epsilon 2
so this number is e to the power of log
cubed and divided by s so eventually in
translating this objective from our
original to this new one we lost this
term this term and this term okay and
now we try to balance these by setting
epsilon 1 and epsilon 2 to be roughly n
to the minus one-third that gives us our
e to the end of the 2/3 what I didn't
tell you is how you handle this one now
that you've made this objective
presumably tractable you Selena solve it
so the way in which we solve it is we
realize that in fact we can convex if I
the subject so instead of trying to find
a biped graph or all of these things are
integers we allow them to be real valued
you can solve this there are still some
things to address which is how do you
take this fractional solution and map it
to a real integer solution turns out
this can be done and you can design it
out oh okay all right so not I'm really
out of time so not gonna say anything
about this one thing I should say is
that in fact you can get this whole
scheme to run in your linear time so you
can run this in your linear time in the
size of your profile alright we did some
experiments it sounds like this is a
complicated algorithm in fact you can
implement it and seem she well we should
have a paper on this in the archive in a
few days so if you want to see more
details I recommend you go over the
paper thank you
[Applause]
question do you expect the problem to be
easier than this if the original
distribution over types is some kind of
generic order stuck in a generic
generousity assumptions so your result
is worst case right yes Arizona
distribution you can get the squaring if
I remove the worst guess assumption it
puts a average-case assumption do you
expect the problem to be easier
still be hard just you're restricting
your maximum assumption about the
district set of distributions that you
might draw this from and presumably it's
simpler but I don't know how to exploit
this I don't know how to exploit the
additional thing yeah I guess it depends
on you know how exactly you choose to
make sure
yeah answer maybe something but somehow
by assuming so it will be the lower
boundary you're assuming as a sort of
boundedness of the support yes yes
support is probably by N squared then
the support size in itself is can never
be bigger than n square so that's some
sort of implicit thing that comes out to
the point is that our goal was to
approximate the profile maximum likely
right so if you have a profile of size n
we're saying that if you restrict
yourself to distributions over suppose
size of n square to n square
you're within a constant factor of this
objective one that's what we're saying
I understand plug this into now yes so
so the point is for support size it
turns out if your insurance supports
Ives you know that you need n over log n
sample so if capital n is a support size
you need to have capital n over log n so
this means that this estimator is going
to be meaningless if you apply it to
support sizes that are smaller right you
never get that right so for that you
have to appeal on a build of the known
results on support size to figure out
what's the sample so what do we know
about the optimal profile do we know for
example that it can be described with
polynomial number of bits what do we
know about the actual distribution that
maximizes the profile you're not talking
about the algorithmic question you're
saying what what do we know about the
distribution that maximizes this okay so
we know a bunch of things and this is
again work of alone or let's key in his
group
one thing we know is that you know in
general there are a bunch of
probabilities and there might be a
continuous part in the end it could be a
portion of receiving that's smeared over
many infinitely many elements or all
with infinitesimal probability so the
distribution is always of this form so
it has a bunch of discrete values and it
may optionally have something that's
mirrored over okay
these these values people have figured
out that they satisfy a bunch of
algebraic equations in fact they've
they've actually used this
characterization to figure out what are
these distributions for all profiles of
size seven after seven so yeah we know a
bunch of different properties but I'm
not sure I think so but I haven't looked
very carefully so I know that they they
sort of characterize these as solutions
to some algebraic equations I don't know
these are if and only if
characterizations first of all and if
this implies that there are a polynomial
size so I think so from non absentia
yeah thank you
[Applause]